[Music]
on this Sunday night feeling the Heat
record high temperatures are fueling
wildfires in western Canada we've broken
over 500 Daily records in the past say a
hundred days
Winds of Change voters across BC choose
new leadership in local elections
Ontario calling an Ottawa doctor leaves
a message for pro-vaccine health workers
in Alberta come on down we've got a job
for you
Plus game over a new study finds a link
between video games and a potentially
deadly heart condition
global national
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us one week after Thanksgiving but
instead of bracing for winter western
Canada is enjoying an extended summer
across BC Alberta Saskatchewan and the
Northwest Territories temperatures are
climbing to record highs of 30 degrees
in some spots well many welcome the
warmer weather those hot and dry
conditions are also fueling fall
wildfires right now there are several
fires burning in BC the regions there
colored in red are most at risk with
extremely dry conditions posing a very
serious fire risk and it's a similar
picture in Alberta with more than 35
wildfires burning in just the last week
as Heather urich's West reports those
Tinder dry conditions are forecast to
get worse
in Calgary the trees certainly show
we're in the midst of autumn but the
temperatures suggest otherwise it's
t-shirt weather maybe even shorts at a
time of year when we often see snow
start to fall it's really been uh not
just a one day or a one-week Wonder it's
just been a prevailing kind of feature
it's a high pressure area a sprawling
Dome a heat Dome it's brought
record-breaking fall temperatures across
the territories and through Saskatchewan
Alberta and BC and Monday's forecast in
Calgary is more of the same we see a
temperature of 26 degrees I mean the
normal high should be 12 and it's 14
degrees warmer than normal and we'll set
an all-time record that goes goes back
to the last century a prolonged summer
in itself isn't necessarily a bad thing
but it's not just hot it's also dry
instead of rain Vancouver residents are
struggling with Smoky skies and poor air
quality as fire Crews across western
Canada battle an unusual amount of
wildfires for this time of year for
example even right now we have 60 active
wildfires across the province one is
classified as out of control 26 are
being held and 33 are under control it's
why there are fire bans or advisories in
place throughout the region Halloween
fireworks activity will also have to be
curtailed the risk of ignition is just
too great this is the second small fire
that we've had this week so we're really
asking people to be vigilant when
they're in the forested areas and be
really careful
it's a far cry from the situation facing
BC nearly a year ago when atmospheric
Rivers were bringing about catastrophic
floods it's more likely in the future
that we're going to see these types of
patterns develop more frequently or year
in and year out with extreme weather
becoming the pattern Canadians will soon
come to expect as calgarians trade in
their snow tires for sunscreen right now
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
change is coming to many City Halls
across British Columbia after a round of
Municipal elections saw a wave of new
candidates beat out longtime incumbents
that includes the province's two biggest
cities where policing and housing were
major factors Catherine urquhart reports
an average four stranger assaults happen
every day in Vancouver crime is a key
concern as is homelessness a tent city
now lines a section of the downtown core
after promising 100 new police officers
and 100 mental health nurses along with
being endorsed by the police Union
mayoral candidate Ken Sim and his ABC
counselors swept to Victory ABC
Vancouver was born out of a desire for
change a desire to do politics
differently Sim Vancouver's First
Chinese Canadian mayor says hiring more
police officers is a priority one of the
first things we will do is we will put a
record requisition in with the Vancouver
Police Department to start the hiring
process policing was also a key issue in
Surrey BC's second largest city Brenda
Locke is now mayor-elect after promising
to keep the RCMP in Surrey reversing the
ongoing transition to a municipal police
force which she had initially supported
on live TV lock boldly announced some
members of the Surrey Police Service
will be fired the senior officers will
be losing their jobs but that's only a
very small number that our inspectors
and the chief for current mayor Doug
McCallum the loss comes just two weeks
before he goes on trial to face a charge
of public Mischief after accusing a
woman of driving over his foot in a
dispute about policing in Surrey she
clipped my knee and in my bottom leg and
then ran over my foot at the same time
and then took off whether in Surrey or
Vancouver policing is a pressing issue
voters making it clear they're ready for
change Catherine urquhart Global News
Vancouver
the new premier of Alberta is capping
off a controversial first week in office
Danielle Smith's claim that unvaccinated
people receive worse discrimination than
any other group in her lifetime sparked
a flurry of reaction including from one
top doctor in Ontario as Tom Vernon
explains he's using Smith's comments as
a recruitment tool hey Toronto thinking
about moving out of Ontario why not
consider Alberta Alberta is calling with
Promises of higher wages and a lower
cost of living although anyone who
answered this week got a new message
they have been the most discriminated
against group that I've ever witnessed
in my lifetime that's new premier
Danielle Smith's feelings about how
unvaccinated Canadians have been treated
during the pandemic the comment spread
quickly and was condemned just as fast
and now Ontario is calling back come on
down we've got a job for you Alex munter
is the head of the Children's Hospital
in Ottawa and they're recruiting seeing
an opportunity he took to Twitter good
morning Alberta healthcare workers we
think racism is bad immunization is good
and we love occupational health and
safety come join us and he's seeing some
interest even a handful of new recruits
out of a tweet uh is pretty good return
on investment the comment has also hit
the pages of Forbes Magazine with senior
contributor and health policy Professor
Bruce y Lee calling the comments harmful
it demeans people who have been
suffering a lot of Injustice uh it makes
it seem like it's not a big deal Premier
Smith hasn't apologized but said she
never intended to trivialize the
Discrimination faced by minority
communities and other persecuted groups
still NDP leader Rachel notley says on
her first day the premier has done
immense harm to Alberta's reputation it
is incumbent upon the new premier to
withdraw her comments
and and apologize acknowledging that she
was wrong marketing Professor David
Silberman says this was definitely a
misstep by the new premier but he
doesn't believe the comments will derail
Alberta's reputation oh I think at the
time it was pretty outrageous but you
know there's a lot of news every day and
within a couple of days I think this
will be in the past Albert is calling
and is leaving a message
Tom Vernon Global News
funeral arrangements have been announced
for the police officers in Innisfil
Ontario who were killed in the line of
duty last week Constable's Morgan
Russell and Devin Michael Northrup will
be honored at a joint funeral in Berry
that's just north of Toronto on Thursday
morning beforehand A procession will
travel from two separate funeral homes
to the arena the ceremony will not be
open to the public the two officers were
shot and killed while responding to a
disturbance call at a home last Tuesday
the 23-year-old gunman was also killed
well weeks after Hurricane Fiona rocked
Atlanta Canada the Nova Scotia
government is now taking aim at
telecommunications companies demanding
more reliable connectivity during major
emergencies Fiona knocked out phone
service for hundreds of thousands across
that region leaving many without the
ability to communicate with Emergency
Services as Ross Lord reports Nova
Scotia is now looking to legislation to
hold the telcos accountable
Nova scotians paid for cell phone
service during Fiona's devastating sweep
through the province but they were
paying for nothing adding to the stress
of fearing for themselves and their
properties many discovered their cell
phones didn't work we had no phone
service there was like a little pocket
in the community where we could just
about get a couple of bars nothing at
all I couldn't get through or get text
messages during the storm if we needed
help
we couldn't contact 9-1-1 Atlanta
Canada's leading phone provider Bell
blamed a battery backup system that's
supposed to keep its Network running
when power is knocked out given the
magnitude of the power outages and as
well the duration of the storm and
thirdly access to sites unfortunately
some of our batteries exhausted not good
enough according to Nova Scotia Premier
Tim Houston the messages do better I
mean it's a it's a critical service we
know that Nova scotians need access to
telecommunications particularly in in
some of these situations that we found
ourselves in over the last couple weeks
Nova scotia's PC government is backing
up its tough talk by imposing new
regulations on phone providers
requirements include an annual
government-approved emergency response
plan physical attendance at emergency
planning sessions under rebate to the
customer for service disruptions the
Nova Scotia government says if telecoms
don't comply they could be hit with
daily fines of up to 250 thousand
dollars the the Telecommunications
industry Canada wide is still reeling
from July's outage on the Rogers system
that disrupted cell networks and
payments for businesses Rogers promises
to spend at least 250 million dollars to
prevent future outages both Bell and
Rogers referred our inquiries about the
new regulations to the Canadian Wireless
telecommunications Association the cwta
did not respond before our deadline the
Nova Scotia government says during Fiona
the service failure hampered emergency
response First Responders and power
Crews were unable to communicate with
each other or with coordination centers
we know action needs to be taken we'll
we'll start that process the federal
government has also signaled it will
take action having already pressed for
more accountability after the Rogers
outage Ross Lord Global News
to the United States now and just weeks
away from crucial midterm elections
early voting is already underway in some
states the balance of power in
Washington is up for grabs as Democrats
try to hold on to control of both the
house and the Senate but the soaring
cost of living Remains the biggest
campaign issue as inflation hits its
highest level in 40 years Jennifer
Johnson reports from Washington
U.S President Joe Biden on the campaign
Trail night after night as the balance
of power in Washington Teeters ahead of
the midterm elections in Oregon the
president was making the case as party
is trying to help struggling Americans I
wrote a thing called the inflation
reduction act this year the American
people won
and for the first time big Pharma lost
but economic losses for the average
American are piling up stock market
accounts are way down mortgage rates and
consumer prices like gas and groceries
are way up a new Associated Press poll
shows 63 percent of Americans disapprove
of Biden's handling of the economy my
wife and I are looking at retirement and
trying to figure out how to do it in
this economy and it's it's challenging
Democrats are hoping to hold on to
control of the Senate and at least two
races are tight in Georgia incumbent
Democrat Rafael Warnock is fighting off
a strong Challenge from Herschel Walker
despite the former football stars
multiple scandals can you tell me why he
voted with Joe Biden 96 percent of the
time and in Pennsylvania Republican
former talk show host Dr mahmet Oz is
battling the state lieutenant governor
for another crucial seat this man has no
core
and he'll say anything for a buck and
while Americans traditionally vote their
pocketbooks Biden is hoping another hot
button issue abortion rights will
Galvanize their base his top economic
priority is fighting inflation but
there's a very clear choice right now
between the policies that we're
advancing and the policies that have
been put forward legislatively by our
Republican friends in Congress still
Democrats are concerned Republicans will
end up controlling Congress blocking
Biden's agenda voters will have to
decide if they can ride out this
troubling economy or if there's more
hope with Republican lawmakers in charge
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
coming up fighting back
russian-controlled regions of Ukraine
come under renewed attack
plus losing trusts the UK's embattled PM
struggles to hold on to her new job
welcome back in the wake of Friday's
deadly Coal Mine blast in Turkey
families of the victims are now
demanding answers from government
officials relatives claim they reported
being able to smell gas for more than a
week before the explosion
funerals continue today for some of the
41 miners killed in that blast 11 others
were injured with at least five still in
critical condition the cause is still
under investigation but officials say
early evidence points to a fire damp
explosion that can occur when methane
mixes with air and fire turning now to
the war in Ukraine where the battle
continues over Russian occupied regions
in the East today a local government
office and russian-controlled Donetsk
was struck by explosions killing at
least one person Russian State media is
blaming Ukrainian shelling though Kiev
has not yet claimed responsibility
meanwhile moscow's defense Ministry
claims they've dealt significant losses
to Ukrainian troops allegedly pushing
back against Ukraine's advances to
retake her son Donetsk and mikalayev
regions
Iranian State media says at least four
people were killed and more than 60
injured following a major fire at
tehran's notorious Evan prison
[Applause]
protesters gathered outside the jail to
demand answers from State officials whom
they say are hiding the true death toll
and the cause of the blaze that facility
which houses many of Iran's political
prisoners was engulfed by fire last
night following weeks of anti-government
protests across the country gunshots and
explosions could also be heard coming
from the site State media which aired
footage of some of the damage has
suggested the fire is not linked to
those ongoing protests
Liz truss's short time as British prime
minister may already be coming to a
close with more MPS joining the calls
for her to resign senior conservatives
will be meeting on Monday for so-called
Rescue Mission talks some MPS want newly
appointed Chancellor Jeremy Hunt to take
over as PM hunt ripped up trusses
controversial tax plan saying she went
too far too fast
in Beijing Stern words from China's
leader Xi Jinping during his opening
speech at the Communist party's Congress
in the nearly two-hour addressed she
boasted about achieving full control
over Hong Kong and refusing to renounce
using Force to unify with Taiwan he also
defended China's strict zero covid
policy saying it put lives above all
else the summit of 2300 party delegates
is also expected to break with tradition
and award she a third term in power
[Music]
still ahead the concerning connection
between video games and heart conditions
in children
one
Health experts have long warned about
the risks of inactivity for people who
spend hours sitting at home playing
video games but a new study suggests an
even more alarming link between video
games and cardiac arrest Kristen
Robinson has the details
gaming is part of growing up for
billions of kids but a new study has
discovered a link between video games
and a potentially deadly heart rhythm
this study is a small sample and it's a
it's an early signal that in some
children I think in certain populations
video games can be dangerous the head of
pediatric cardiology at BC Children's
Hospital among the researchers who found
22 cases around the world where children
blacked out while gaming 6 or 27 percent
experienced cardiac arrest and four or
eighteen percent died suddenly all of
the kids were aged 7 to 16 19 or 86
percent were male
multiplayer war games were the most
frequent trigger I don't know if that
just represents the proportion of games
that are being played anyways so is that
a normal sample or is that a skewed
sample so it's you know we don't have
enough data to really you know ascertain
the report published in heart rhythm
found a pro-arythmic cardiac diagnosis
was known in seven or 31 percent of the
children before they lost Consciousness
and was established afterward in 12 or
54 percent I think we have to start
thinking about treating video games as a
much more exciting activity than we that
we've been uh acknowledging and so you
know probably talking about it and that
there is some risk video games are
probably safe for the vast majority of
people these inherited heart rhythm
conditions are rare
the bottom line high-risk players Dr
shubayan sanatani says should take
precautions before engaging in the
electronic war zone Kristen Robinson
Global News
[Music]
up next talking trash the remarkable
relationship between an Alberta toddler
and his garbage collector
[Music]
welcome back taking out the trash can be
dirty work but an Alberta Community just
west of Calgary is getting some unlikely
help with their garbage from a toddler
Jill cruto has more on a
three-year-old's heartwarming affinity
for Waste Management this
toddler knows his trash right after
Nolan took his first steps his
fascination with garbage trucks was
undeniable
he's nowhere near as big as the bins but
he Maneuvers them all out to the alley
every Thursday night and then bright and
early Friday morning he waits Daddy
and watches
he's come to a door it's the man behind
the wheel good morning Clint Jack is his
garbage man
my weekend was awesome thank you for
asking any connection between them is
about the purest thing ever there's a
friendship there he's a good kid I do
believe he calls me his best friend
which is pretty cool I I really love
that I really love that
their attachment to each other has been
endearing to watch develop it's a good
feeling you know look he he looks out
for me and you know I every week I try
to make him happy it's never an
obligation for Clint he always takes
time to indulge this little boy's every
request
everybody gets in return his gratitude
beyond words
to know that there are still people who
will take the time to entertain a
three-year-old who has a serious
obsession with garbage trucks his uh
it's it's remarkable and we're we're so
thankful that he gets to experience that
and he has people like that in his life
who show him true kindness to have
somebody a complete stranger show love
and affection for her son is
um it's incredible oh he's there it's a
bond they all expect he'll likely
outgrow but until that day comes they
will cherish every moment have a good
day do I get a high five
oh good
[Music]
jokes Global News
one toddler's trash is another's
treasure great work Nolan that is global
national for this Sunday night I'm Jeff
Semple tonight's your Canada is Lake
Erie from Rock Point Provincial Park in
Ontario we would love to see your
candidates so please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching Donna Friesen will be back at
the anchor desk with you tomorrow